hello everyone and welcome to the
long-awaited report regarding the
Endeavors of Hans Neiman it was
published by chess.com yesterday I think
they published it uh not by themselves
they've given it to like the guardian or
some other portals but today they have
published their findings um via their
personal account on Twitter so I will
share that with you will be the first
link you will see in the description
below it contains 72 pages regarding uh
Hans Neiman and his Play Over the board
and online and in comparison to the
other players and a lot of interesting
stuff is in here so if you want to go
through it uh through everything you
will be able to it's in the description
below I will just quickly go over it to
give you a general idea of what their
findings were so it says chess.com's
current research and findings October
22. over the last few weeks the world's
been following the major story regarding
Hans Neiman Magnus Carlsen and cheating
in chess this has become a matter of a
significant public interest both inside
and outside the Chess World and we
present in this report our exploration
of the event circumstances and the data
that have informed chess.com's decision
uh concerning the current controversy as
well as the issue of cheating interests
more generally at the outset we want to
make clear that while these events
highlight a critical Topic in chess
cheating the vast majority of chess
games do not involve any cheating we
estimate that fewer than 0.14 percent of
players on chess.com ever cheat and that
our events are by uh are by and large
free from cheating we firmly believe
that cheating in chess is rare
preventable and the much less pervasive
than is currently being portrayed in the
media with that background the following
is a brief summary of our findings and
takeaways on 72 pages so basically this
is uh their conclusion in short you can
read this and then we're gonna go go
through the 72 pages but fairly quickly
so we present evidence in this report
that Hans likely cheated online much
more than his public statements suggest
however while Hans has had a
record-sitting and remarkable rise in
rating and strength in our view there is
a lack of concrete statistical evidence
that he cheated in his game with Magnus
or in any other over the board game
or in-person games we are presenting our
findings here and will cooperate with
fide on any further investigation so
basically they've said that um uh well
it's pretty clear the game against
Magnus is legit other over the board
games are legit and it would seem that
uh while uh he did cheat and he admitted
to cheating he cheated in many more
games that then was previously thought
we were never pressured by Magnus or his
team whatsoever to remove Hans from
chess.com or revoke his invitation to
the chess.com Global Championship nor
did we communicate with Magnus regarding
our decision on these issues before we
made them in fact Magnus did not even
know we were going to remove Hans until
Hans went public with our private
correspondence we Uninvited Hans from
our upcoming major online events and
revoked his access to our site based on
our experience with him in the past
growing suspicions among top players and
their team about his rapid rise of play
the strange circumstances and
explanations of his win over Magnus as
well as magnus's unprecedented
withdrawal in order to have more time to
investigate the over-the-board situation
and our own internal concerns we
Uninvited Hans from our events and
prevented his access to chess.com we are
open to continuing a dialogue with Hans
to discuss his status on chess.com
we believe that chess organizers
federations companies and players can
all work together more effectively to
create great and assurely fair chess
events so here you can read about the
mission of chess.com what what they
strive to do what they what they stand
for and then you have a timeline of
events that we are interested in so
September 4 2022 Magnus Carlsen having
the white beasts and Hans Neiman having
the black pieces play a game at the same
field Cup in St Louis in which Hans wins
and Hans gives a post-game interview
September 5th the day after Magnus
tweets his withdrawal from the event
linking to a video clip in which a
soccer manager can be heard saying I
prefer really not the speak if I speak
I'm in big trouble the the Mourinho one
chess.com emails hunts privately to let
him know that his account has been
discreetly closed and his invitation to
the uh just.com Global Championship has
been withdrawn a copy of this email is
attached as exhibit a it has
historically been chess.com's General
policy to handle accounts suspensions
closers and invitations for title
players such as Hansa in a non-public
matter
the a list of exhibits will be at the
end of this document if you ever go
through it so September 6th uh Hans
publicly addresses his Batman chess.com
stating that although he cheated a few
years ago when he was 12 and 16 years
old he has never cheated in a tournament
with prize money when I was streaming or
in a real game September 8 2022
chess.com sends Hans a letter personally
laying out the reasons for the decisions
to revoke his status on chess.com and to
disinvite him to the just.com global
championship of which a copy of which is
attached as exhibit B chess.com responds
to Hunt's public comments via tweet
Below in image one we've already had
this on the channel but for those of you
who are maybe new to this dear chess
Community the last few days have been
cumulus for many in the chess community
at this time we have reached out to Hans
demon to explain our decision to
privately remove him from chess.com and
our events we have shared detailed
evidence with him concerning our
decision including information that
contradicts his statements regarding the
amount of seriousness of his cheating on
chess.com we have invited Hans to
provide an explanation and response with
the hope of finding a resolution where
Hans can again participate on chess.com
we want nothing more than to see the
best chess players in the world succeed
in the greatest events we will always
act to protect the Integrity of the game
that we all love signed the Danny wrench
Chief chess officer and then you have
September 27th Magnus releases a public
statement explaining his unprecedented
unprecedented professional decision to
withdraw from the singfield copy
indicates that he believes that Neiman
has cheated more and more recently than
he has publicly admitted
uh then you have uh their basis of
decision to remove hands from chess.com
and withdraw his chess.com uh Global uh
Championship uh you you can read that uh
can't believe that Hans cheated in his
September 4th over the board game
against Magnus Carlson in the scenefield
cup and more generally do we believe
Hans has cheated in other over the board
games and here it says despite the
public speculation and these uh these
questions in our view there is no direct
evidence that proves Hans cheated at the
September 4th uh 2022 game with Magnus
or proves that he has cheated in other
over the board games that said as set
forth more fully Below in section X We
Believe certain aspects of the September
4 game were suspicious and hans's
explanation of his win post event added
to our suspicion as to his over the
board play more generally in section 7
below we discuss what we believe are
apparent anomalies enhances rise in over
the board rating of note we discuss how
Hans became the fastest fastest rising
top player in classical over the board
chess in modern recorded history much
later in life than his peers and did it
after we had removed him from our
playing and playing on our side in 2020.
despite these potential suspicions as
shown Below in Section 8 our in-depth
review of Hans is over the board games
using chess.com statistical methods
revealed aggregate patterns of play that
while interesting are possible for a
rising player approaching 2700 in
section 9 we present hans's top
performing events based on his over
performance in strength and rating we
are prepared to cooperate with fide and
respect their role in leading this and
any future over-the-board investigations
uh then it says if chess.com was not
certain that Hans cheated at the sinful
cup why did they take steps to revoke
his invitation to the cgc and close his
chess.com account in the wake of his
match with Magnus and then they said uh
of course we basted this decision on
several factors first as detailed in
this report Hans admitted to cheating in
chess games on our site as recently as
2020 after our cheating detection
software and team uncovered suspicious
plays second we had suspicions about
Hans plagon's Magnus at the single cup
which were intensified by the public
Fallout from the event third we had
concerns about uh the step the Steep
inconsistent rise in hans's rank uh set
out in section 7 of this report like
others in the broader chess Community
finally we faced a critical decision
point at an unfortunate time could we
ensure the Integrity of the cgc which
was scheduled to start a few days after
the sinful Cup on September 14 2022 for
all participants if Hans took part in
the event They concluded that it was not
possible and then uh he was uninvited so
okay you can read a bit more about that
yourself but I'm more interested in the
in the cheating part Hans cheating on
chess.com uh consistent with the letter
uh we sent Hans privately on September 8
we are prepared to show within this
report that he in fact appears to have
cheated again multiple opponents in
chess.com prize events beyond the title
Tuesday events that Hans admitted to
having cheated in when he was 12. speed
Chess Championship qualifiers and the
protest League we also have evidence
that uh he appears to have cheated in
sets of rated games sanchez.com against
highly rated well-known figures in the
chess Community some of which he
streamed online these findings
contradict uh hans's public statements
in particular in the interview that Hans
is given in the 2022 singfield cup he
gave several comments to the Press about
alleged instances of Prior cheating
other than uh when I was 12 years old I
have never ever ever and I would never
do that uh that is the worst thing that
I could ever do cheat in a tournament
with prize money never when I was
streaming did I cheat and keep in mind
that I was 16 years old I never wanted
to hurt anyone these were random games I
would never uh could even fathom doing
it in a real game as discussed in more
detail below with this we disagree with
these statements that's just that common
the fair play team is a sophisticated
internal analytical team that assesses
potential cheating cases on our platform
common types of cheating examples range
from every move is an engine move where
every move played was the top a move
recommended by the engine two we don't
have enough evidence to close uh where
where the players moves are usually
unusually sophisticated but still within
realistic bounds of statistical
probability we have gathered detailed
evidence on hans's play and have
determined through extensive review of
that evidence that there were numerous
games where hans's gameplay fell along
this spectrum strongly suggesting that
he violated Our Fair Play regulations
now do with that information what you
will here are some of the events that
he supposedly cheated in uh some like
title Tuesday qualifiers for the uh for
something protest league in the games
against narditsky in the in the Grand
Prix title Tuesday Blitz against krikor
games against paravian against Yani
punish against German uh private match
versus Benjamin Bok then again uh in
2020 you can see in the in the title
Tuesday blitz so overall we have found
that Hans has likely cheated in more
than 100 online games including several
prize money events he was already 17
when he likely cheated in some of these
matches and games he was also streaming
in 25 of this game of these games so it
says while his performance in some of
these matches may seem to be within the
realm of some statistical possibility
the probability of any single player
performing this will across uh this many
games is incredibly low now what I find
interesting is that
the the the evidence that that is that
well that they come up with is that
basically this the probability of any
single player are performing this well
across this many games is incredibly low
which means that if ever in the future a
a player is born that has this ability
it will be considered impossible now I I
don't know as I mean none of this is
concrete evidence is just a you know the
probability of him playing this well is
very unlikely so I don't know
again do do with it what you will uh so
okay then you have some private Comfort
uh conversation between the narrange and
Hans Neiman regarding all of this you
can read that yourself uh then you have
how cheat detection works you can also I
I'm just going to read the basic concept
of cheat detection is basically uh
comparing the moves made to an engine
recommended move removing some moves
opening some end game because of course
those are not cheating but you can learn
the openings you can learn the end game
focusing on key critical moves
discussing with a panel of trained
analysts and strong players comparing
players uh past performance and no
strength profile comparing a player's
performance to Performance of comparable
peers looking at the statistical
significance of the results looking at
if there are behavioral factors at play
and reviewing time usage when compared
to the difficulty of the moves on the
board now this is also something that I
uh like imagine if someone is actually
really strong like as as Hans is
appearing to be and his games and moves
are reviewed by players who are not as
strong then of course they their idea
would be that it is impossible to play
Such moves um so fast so I don't know uh
well I'm sure very capable people have
done this analysis uh you know I I as a
you know just someone who enjoys chess I
don't know uh I'm not convinced so
chess.com employs highly rated and a
grand master Fairplay analyst precisely
because there are many situations where
humans are required to understand how
human versus computer a move would
actually is a move actually is human
chess and computer chess are different
even at the highest levels the best
humans play at the nilo rating of 2800
stockfish the most powerful chess engine
has an estimated rating of more than
3500 so there is quite quite the
difference in a theoretical match
between world champion Magnus Carlsen
versus stockfish we estimate that it is
most likely that Magnus Carlsen would
lose every single game no wins and no
draws okay every no one is doubting that
uh okay so here you can read about their
Best in Class sheet detection and
selective cheating you can read that on
your own uh here are some of the
uh when he had me admitted to cheating
on just that come in 2020 hunts had an
international Master title with at least
one Grand Master norm and the
performance that ultimately led to the
action of having his account closed that
was benchmarked with a strength score of
85.50 uh strength score is something
that they give to a player uh well
basically depending on how strong he
plays uh like Magnus would have okay but
we're gonna discuss that later on as the
the strength scores are uh nicely shown
between other players as well then you
have hans's over the board rise outside
his online play hunts is the fastest
rising top player in classical
over-the-board chess in modern history
with each new generation of players
there is a small group who will
eventually emerge at the top as the top
players some of the big names in the
current generation are alireza firo
javins and kymer arjunergesi looking
purely at raiding hunts should be
classified as a member of this group of
top young players while we do not doubt
that Hans is a talented player we noted
that his results are statistically
extraordinary now the increase in
strength there you can see the this is
the the strength rating over over the
course of the years for example here uh
they've put it from the beginning of
2014 to the end of 2022. uh then you can
see Hans Neiman uh has made the the
absolute biggest progress from 2014 uh
to the end of 2022 uh from a score
strength score of 67.7 to 90 which is a
yearly gain of 2.66 whereas Vincent
kymer who is second here made from 72 in
2014 to 91 in 2022. so his uh weighted
yearly gain is 2.22 some 0.4 points uh
below Hans Neiman but then you have
domaraju cash also below Vincent camera
some 0.2 points behind him then
already
so those are the uh young players that
are basically running the Chess World
now foreign
the difference in their their strength
from 2014 to 2022 for example you see
andreasipenko has an 84 at the start of
2014 and then 88 at the end of 2022 so
he did not make uh he made progress but
it was not as big he was already
incredibly strong in 2014 unlike for
example Hans who had a score of 67 and
then at the end of 2022 a score of 90.
uh but okay then we have some uh okay
here we have something uh also you can
see no no that's not the one I want to
show you uh nor this nor this nor this
you can check that out by yourself that
the ages of the grand Masters as Set uh
fourth in a table for another key data
uh point that informed our analyst is
the fact that there are 13 players
currently ranked in the world's top 50
players who are younger than 25. Hans is
the only player who became a grand
master at the age of 17 the other 12
players all all achieved the title
between the ages of 12 and 16. so as you
can see Hans could be a a late bloomer
hans's over-the-board data analysis
while cheers.com's cheat detection is
tuned to catch cheating in our faster
online time controls we started off
hans's over the board play using the
same statistical tools and compared him
to his peers given his outstanding rise
in strength and rating we considered
several questions
um and examined the relevant data with
the intention to investigate whether
Hans has cheated over the board how does
Hans strength over the board compare to
other players and this is also very very
interesting to me we analyzed all over
the board games played by these players
against 200 20 2500 plus rated opponents
so anyone who is above a Grand Master
Level since the start of 2022 and
calculated their overall strength score
Hans is ranked number six of 13 so
somewhere in the middle nothing
spectacular
as is shown in figure H this puts him
roughly in the middle of a somewhat
tight band of strength scores which is
not on its own uh noteworthy uh you can
see uh he is yeah the the blue one is
Hans for example the the highest one uh
has a nihal sarin even even higher than
Magnus Carlsen uh does Hans have an
unusually uh shaped plot of games based
on strength score a player who plays
differently at the different times uh
might show two separate distributions of
game strength which might look more like
two lumps uh not an even distribution
Hans distribution graph looks similar to
those of his peers with a fairly simple
and apparently unimodal distribution
these graphs are contained in appendix
10.1 or x.1 it will be a later shown
once hans's rise in strength not raining
in strength sudden jumping from a 2500
player of play immediately up to a 2650
plus level of play which might indicate
unnatural growth or did his strength
follow a more natural progression the
data based on chess.com strength score
enhances games and events does not
necessarily indicate a stepwise
progression that you might see if a
player suddenly went from one level of
strength to another it's not like saying
okay he just went Super Saiyan at some
point we graphed his performance in
events by strength score over time and
compared it to his peers in appendix x.2
Okay blah blah blah Hans has played an
unusually high number of near perfect
games and here also very interesting
there has been some analysis posted
online suggesting Hans has played an
abnormally High number of perfect games
we have carefully analyzed many other
presentations found online that claim to
have found potential evidence of
cheating uh including uh asserting that
Hans has played more 100 games uh uh uh
Etc we have concluded that the
methodology and the underlying tools
used in those analyzes do not meet our
standard you all know who they are
talking about uh therefore chess.com
gathered all of huntses and other uh
related players games from 2020 onward
played against 2500 plus rated players
and removed any games we determined were
lacking sufficient measurable
observations uh based on our process of
removing known book moves and some
simple endgame moves and then measured
the percentage of those games which were
above 100 on our strength scores So
based on this analysis as she is shown
in figure one Hans actually has one of
the lower percentages of near perfect
games when compared to the similar
players so there you have it if you want
to consider who plays the most perfect
games Hans is uh below the middle uh
here there there's like a person Jordan
Farm Forest pregnant
and all the way to the right of course
uh by far the the biggest number of
perfect games or near Perfect Games is
played by none other than of course
Magnus cross and uh followed uh
following Magnus or another back
abdusarin and then uh the rest would be
andreasipenko Arjun irrigation Vincent
kaimer and gookish and so on so so Hans
is nowhere near uh any of them
in terms of perfect play in conclusion
while we cannot definitively prove that
hans's rise in strength is entirely
natural we have also found no indication
in the game data to suggest otherwise uh
while uh some have suggested that a move
by move analysis by human May uh surface
some Oddities in move choice or analysis
there is nothing in our statistical
investigation to raise any red flags
regarding hans's over the board play and
rise and the rest of it is
um uh pretty much uh uh the single cup
okay in the game against Magnus Carlsen
finally the game between hunts and
Magnus at the single Cub does on its own
Merit analysis as its result
circumstances and explanations are
unique and have become the object of
immense public debate and controversy
hunts beat Magnus in a classical game
with the black pieces breaking magnus's
53 game unbeaten streak and becoming one
of the only five players in the past
five years the beat Magnus while he was
playing with the white pieces Hans
explained that his success was not
anything special and largely due to
Magnus having played quite poorly and
having miraculously prepared
specifically for the opening that Magnus
played by some miracle I had checked
this today and it's like it's such a
ridiculous miracle that I don't even
remember why I checked it now while that
in itself might sound like a weird story
uh I mean there's nothing that would
suggest that it it it's it's not true I
mean at least to me in fact Magnus has
only played a Ford G3 uh that's a move
twice previously both before 2010 in the
position after Hans Castle then move
four had never been seen in any of
magnus's games
hunting a later in an interview
commented that Magnus had previously
played the opening against Wesley so in
the 2018 London chess classic but there
is no such game on record Magnus did
play G3 ninja against Wesley saw in a
rapid game in Kolkata in 2019 but the
move ordered an emerging position in
that game had no similarities to the
game against Hans hans's uh 9C captures
on the forehead only been played once
previously in the June 2022 title
Tuesday game between erasm of Swan and
Stelios halkias so there you have it in
the post game analysis on move 13 hans's
proposed Hans proposed the error uh 13
queen queen H4 saying Queen H4 might be
a move here this move loses the bishop
on G5 without any obvious conversation
or or compensation or the follow-up at
this moment among others led to
criticism from other top chess players
who were surprised that a player who
could outplay Magnus so easily with the
black pieces could the then suggest such
a move in a game that he had just played
after proposing uh the move hands
requested to see the engine evaluation
saying what does it say uh what does the
engine say to confirm that this move
lacked a purpose uh these this analysis
and dependence on the engine seem to be
at odds with the level of preparation
that Hans claimed was at play in the
game and the level of analysis needed to
defeat the world champion so uh do what
that you know what you will we also
measured that uh for the first three
games of the single Hub uh Hans played
with a chess.com strength score of 97.17
after round three the event organizers
in response to the cheating allegations
added a 15-minute delay to the broadcast
of a chess move for rounds four to nine
Hans achieved a strength score of
86.31 which is lower but with uh again
with everything if if you you know
imagine a world where Hans did not
actually cheat and uh you know in the
over the board game and the entire world
was tweeting at him you know uh the
every every big uh you know news portal
was sharing news about him cheating that
would affect your concentration at least
a little bit regardless of of your you
know mental capacity so other players
also had some interesting changes in
strength as measured by chess.com this
can be attributed to any number of
factors including the ensuing situation
after Magnus withdrew uh different
opponents and so on in our view no
conclusions should be should be made
from this data but of course everyone
will make their own conclusions uh uh so
okay uh is there anything else that we
need so in conclusion after Hans beat
Magnus and Magnus withdrew from the
sinful cup we removed hands from just
that comes upcoming Grand chess uh sorry
nhl.com Global Championship uh should be
cgc no and we drew his access to the
site until we could conduct further
review and while magnus's actions
prompted us to reassess the situation
Magnus did not talk Us in advance about
our decisions or ask for it or directly
influence those decisions at all Magnus
was in this operating entirely under his
own direction as it's just.com however
given the circumstances which included a
player who had a significant and
admitted history of cheating the world
chess champion making the loudest
statement in chess history and an
Invitational event starting in a matter
of days we felt uh we had to act we
communicated privately with Hans via
email we never wanted or intended to
have a public discussion about these
decisions and frankly we believe we
could have resolved things more
privately
we understand that the timing of our
email uh enhance publicizing of it may
have led to a number of people in the
chess Community to believe that
chess.com knew Hans was cheating over
the board or was under pressure from
Magnus or had some new evidence
indicating that Hans was cheating over
the board the much less interesting
truth is that none of this is true while
there are many remarkable signals and
unusual patterns in Hans uh hans's path
as a player and while some games
behaviors and actions are hard to
understand chess.com is unaware of any
concrete evidence proving that Hans is
cheating over the board or has ever
cheated over the board chess.com has
historically not been involved in over
the board or classical chess fair play
decisions as we do not run over the
board or classical chess events our
investigation has revealed that while
there has been some noteworthy online
play that has caught our attention as
suspicious since August 2020 we are
unaware of any evidence that Hans has
engaged in online cheating since then
our investigation has concluded that he
did however cheat much more than he has
publicly admitted including in many
prized events at least 25 streamed games
and 100 plus rating games on chess.com
as recently as when he was 17 years old
We Believe Hans is an incredibly strong
player and a talented individual that
said given his history on our site we
did not believe we could ensure that he
would play fairly in our online events
until we could reevaluate the evidence
and our protocols nevertheless and to be
clear it is not our position that hunts
should be limited or banned from Over
the board chess Hans is online and
over-the-board behaviors may be
completely different and that should be
taken into consideration we have shared
our findings with fide and will corrupt
or cooperate with any investigation or
request they pursue uh it is our belief
that over the board event organizers
should be taking much stronger
precautions against cheating by all
players to ensure a fair planes to keep
the game fair all players should be
playing under the same conditions and
check before during and after the
matches uh using the appropriate
Technologies and methods to counter any
outside assistance we reiterate our
message of September 8 2022 that we
would like to have a conversation with
Hans to provide an explanation and
response with the hope of finding a
resolution where hunts can again
participate on chess.com we wanted the
best for Hans we want the best for
magnets we wanted the best for chess we
want stability fairness and joy in the
chess Community not turbulence
conspiracy and accusations we have a
role to play in this and we acknowledge
that we can do better in our
transparency timing and messaging moving
forward and look forward to cooperating
with fide and others in the chess
Community to serve the game Eric Dany
and the fair play team and chess.com and
okay then you have all of the evidence
that was mentioned uh throughout these
20 Pages you can check it out I will put
it in the description below it's quite
quite extensive you can read pretty much
everything on your own but this is
basically just uh uh
evidence and everything in detail what
we've just uh gone through so that's
basically it what they are saying is
that Hans yes did cheat online we all
know that he cheated in more games than
he he admitted uh I think pretty much we
all knew that as well but that there is
no indication that after 2020 yeah he
cheated anywhere and uh well they have
no indication whatsoever that he he
cheated in any over the board game and
especially in the game against Magnus
Carlsen uh and as you've seen there are
many many more players uh with the
Incredible strength scores as they use
that term on chess.com uh you can see
that Magnus is far far above everyone
else so so it's I mean it's not even
close what is in interesting is uh yeah
hans's incredible Ascent from from 2500
to 2700 or even from 24 I don't know uh
that uh that table we've shown where he
uh he has the absolute uh a biggest
progression uh in modern chess history I
don't know why they use modern chess
history uh does anyone have a bigger
progression I think it's just because
they they can't measure a progression of
let's say Bobby Fisher or someone like
that uh but yeah there we have it that's
the Hans Neiman report Uh chess.com's
current research and finding from
October 2022 what do you take from this
uh does this uh you know uh what what
does this mean to you I mean uh it it
really does not move my opinion I I
stand by you know unless something is
proven I mean there's no reason to
believe he cheated over the board uh but
uh as usual I'm always interested in
what you guys think because you always
have such such a great opinions and you
know I love reading your comments uh so
yeah uh that's uh the the report hope
you guys enjoyed that I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to Peter and
I would like to thank tasulia I love you
Alan Bradberry as the Grand and storm 70
on bandcamp for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day